Every tongue shall confess, every knee
shall bow that Jesus Christ is Lord to
the glory of God the Father.
>> Jesus is Lord.
>> It's really good.
>> Bacon.
>> Bacon. Anybody?
>> This is one video. If you care about the
more than skip it by one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who have been
fed through the emergency food aid. You
are going to be sponsoring 4,200
orphans. You will be helping 250,000
people in Gaza. You'll be helping
123,000 people to be fed through our
Kmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one um 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund. So that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on your makyama. The decision
is yours. The link is there. Donate now.
Asalama to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys So this is a
video that really enraged me. Let's
watch it for ourel. Um I'm going to try
my best to um not insult these absolute
coward of a dirt bags. Um these are
these are these are um absolute scums.
Um I think I'm not doing well at all. I
feel I really started bad. But watch the
video and tell me that you know look at
these cowards. Look how look how
disgusting they are. They are group of
brothers who are praying and look at the
way they are talking and the utter
hypocrisy. They hate Islam so much and
they know Islam is the truth. These
cowards like this wall if they were to
come and the challenge Allah says in the
Quran bring your family I'll bring my
family. We're taken off by Allah. May
the curse fall on the one that's a liar.
They will not do it. They are cowards.
Let's watch it for ourel inshallah.
Every tongue shall confess, every knee
shall bow that Jesus Christ is Lord to
the glory of God the Father.
>> Jesus is Lord.
>> Bacon. It's really good.
>> Bacon.
>> Bacon. Anybody?
>> Under the new rules from the 12th imam,
you can eat bacon. It's halal. You can
eat bacon whenever you want.
>> So you can see what kind of degenerates
they are. Like absolutely. I think they
look like, you know, I think the
intellect level is on the minus. Like, I
don't think they have a brain. I mean,
is this your argument? Jesus is Lord to
the glory of the father. Oh, is this we
thought Jesus was God? Oh, John 17:3.
The only only true God is who? The
father. H. But I thought Jesus was God.
Is Jesus the only true God? Uh-uh. Do
you see your ideology, your theology is
is is collapsed from the get-go? And I
can remember it's it reminds me of a a
Unitarian in the I can't remember which
which century it was from. He said how
much longer the Muhammad is going to
laugh to laugh about us with the
Trinity. It's the most illogical
irrational thing ever and all you can do
is eat bacon about it. Carry on eating
bacon, mate. Because you know what's
funny? Did Jesus eat bacon? Oh yeah, he
didn't. Was Jesus circumcised? Oh yeah,
he was. Was his mother wearing a hijab?
Oh yes, he was. In the mountain of
Gethsemane, did he fall on his face and
pray? Yes. Does he praise the father?
Yes. Sounds like a bloody Muslim, mate.
H. Okay. Now, let's carry on to another
camera angle of these dirt bags getting
more vile and vile. And we're going to
expose them. We're going to, you know
what we're going to do? We're going to
use the same standard. Their Jesus, not
the Jesus that we know is Jesus of the
Old Testament of of the Bible and the
prophet Muhammad peace upon him who is
more high in moral charact character.
That's what they love to do. Yeah. Let's
go there, my friend. I'm going to
absolutely decimate you, destroy you,
intellectually finish you off. Watch
this.
You can eat bacon whenever you want.
>> God commands you to repent. Muhammad is
a pedophile. You're praying to a man
who's burning in hell. He married a
9-year-old girl and you're Muhammad.
[snorts]
I spit on the grave of Muhammad.
>> Don't do that.
>> You're going to make that noise in
hellfire. You know that you're going to
do that when you're eating eating from
the tree of Yes. You're going to do that
inshallah. Yeah. So, may Allah subhanaa
tala guide you. May Allah curse you.
Okay. So your argument is what? The
prophet peace of married Aisha at uh 9
at 9. That makes him a pedophile. Number
one, most pedophiles look like you with
loads of respect. Most the pedophile
issue of pedophilia in the UK, in
Australia, in America, around the world,
in Canada are white middle-aged men. My
friend, you fit that criteria more than
anyone. Go to Google and write
pedophiles. Your face might pop up. You
might be like, "Yo, damn, that guy looks
like me. HE LOOKS PRETTY LIKE YOU, MAN.
You might flipping is my picture there."
What they like, "Oh, damn." you know,
he's identical to you, my friend. Middle
white age men, Epstein islands, they all
look like you. This is not our problem.
And not only that, let's talk about
morality. If I'm not mistaken, in the
book of Numbers 31:18, it says that when
you go to a land and kill the men,
women, and children, and the women that
have not been touched by men, I think
it's talking about virginity, keep them
for yourself to do what? To play
monopoly. Hold on a second. Who is this
talking? This is Jesus, the God of the
Old Testament, commanded to do this. So,
is he a pedophile? The the the the the
corrupt Jesus of your Bible, not the
Isaam that we know. Is he a pedophile?
You dirt bag. Let's carry on. Yes. Oh,
it's backfiring now. Okay, I'm going to
throw the Bible away now. Yes. Which one
is more higher? A God or a prophet? God,
right? Well, your God is the immoral
stuff. What happened to in if I'm not
mistaken, Galatians? Okay. If I'm uh I
don't know exactly which chapter 13:3.
Yes. When it says that when a man rapes
a woman, guess what? He can marry her by
paying 50 shekels to the father and
she's not allowed to divorce him. What
happened to woman's rights? Rape. In
Islam, a man who rapes a woman gets a
capital punishment. Let's carry on.
>> Muhammad is going to Muhammad is in
hell. You're going to burn in hell. You
need to repent. You need to get saved
and set free. Jesus Christ is coming
soon. TAKE THAT TOWEL off of your head.
Take that. Hey,
>> let him go. Let him go. Let him go. Back
up. Back up. Back up. Back up. Back up.
Back up. Back up. Muslim. Back up. Your
book tells you to fight those who don't
believe in Allah. Fight. That's why he
did that. Because your book tells you to
do. You're about to do the Quran circle
and recite the exact thing that he did
because your god is the devil and you're
going to hell unless you repent and
accept Jesus. Jesus saved and defeated
death.
>> So interesting. You go there incite
violence. Okay.
um aggravate them, okay? Try to provoke
them and then oh your book teaches that.
You flipping You absolute
flipping What kind of brain cell
do you even have any brain cells? Okay,
you're going to go to someone. Imagine a
Muslim does that to a group of
Christians. What would you guys do?
Would you like, yeah, Jesus said, "Turn
the other cheek." No, you wouldn't. Yes.
If anything, you're talking about jihad.
In your book, it says to kill innocent
men, women, children, babies, and
donkeys. Yeah. Even tells you to kill
you, which you're a donkey. Yeah. Okay.
So the question is show me a single
verse in the Quran that says go and kill
innocent men, women, children, babies
and donkeys. I thought Jesus was the
more hor the god of the Old Testament
was very high in morality. Killing
innocent men, women and children and
babies and donkeys. Yes. The question is
what did the donkey do? I've been asking
this question for the past 13 years. We
don't know. Let's carry on.
>> I've been threatened with death. That's
the difference. You guys hate people in
the name of God. We love people in the
name of God. That's why we're
>> they love us. You know was it [laughter]
Orthodox Muslim or Reddine responds? He
said there is no greater hatred than
Christian love. There is no greater
hatred than Christian love. This is the
love they're talking about. Can you you
can't make this up? Can you imagine me
going insulting someone and go, you know
what I'm doing cuz I love you. That's
because you guys hate people because
you're stupid fake prophet who took IT
UP THE BUTT and married a six-year-old.
>> Hate people. The irony, guys. The You
can't make this stuff up. The irony.
He's there preaching hatred, insulting a
prophet of another religion. Yes. And
then he has the audacity to come and say
you hate. Imagine me going and ripping
the Bible, insulting insulting these
people. And then afterwards I go, your
religion teaches hatred. Are you a
Like seriously, are you that
stupid? Are you that idiotic? Yes. And
you can see, subhan Allah, that they
have nothing. Because anyone that has to
resort to violence, has to resort to
name calling, has to resort to violence
and all this kind of stuff. It just
shows you are intellectually bankrupt.
You have nothing to offer. What do you
have to offer? Nothing. Intellectually,
you get buried and you get buried on a
daily basis by Shakman Faruk, by Muslim,
by response, by Mansur, Hashim,
Muhammad, Hijab, you name it. The list
goes on. You guys get buried on a daily
basis. And because you can't deal with
that fact, you come with what? Insults.
That's all you have. So, as we can see,
guys, not all Christians are the same.
Allah tells in the Quran, not all
Christians are the same. And these are
dirt bags who always like to cause
trouble. That's what they are known for.
And this happened in Islamic Spain. The
book is called Martyrs of Cordoba. Yes,
these were where Christians were
flocking to Islam. And certain hate
preachers, Christian hate preachers took
took it on themsel to be like, how can
we reverse this? Because Islam is the
truth and people are flocking to Islam.
You know what they would do? It's called
mart of go and read the book. They would
go out in public in Islamic squares.
Yes. and insult the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him knowing there's a
capital punishment and they will receive
the capital punishment so their
Christian fellow Christians can be like
oh they're persecuting us no Muslims and
Christians and Jews were living in peace
these Christians came out and they
started insulting the prophet why so
they can make people sympathize with
them that's how desperate they are and
Islam is the truth and it's the huck and
people are flocking to Islam on our dow
tables all I'm going to say is that
brother and sisters these hate preachers
will be hate preachers we're going to
carry on doing our work we're at our
dowo tables around the world
alhamdulillah thousands yesterday we had
two Christian girls come to Islam. You
can't stop the truth. Like Jesus said,
seek the truth and it the truth shall
set you free. Islam's number one reason
people come to Islam means you know why
by Christianity is because the trinity
doesn't make sense. Can you imagine
someone saying toi doesn't make sense.
I'm going to leave it at that. Inshallah
sisters, may Allah guide these people or
deal with them inshallah and give them a
end that they remember for the rest of
their life.
Don't lie about a cattle.